مشاريع صغيره لكنها تحمل امال كبيره ل 50
اسره من الايتام في مارب
استفادت من مشروع الكفاله الذي ماوله مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
مشاريع مكانت الاسري من العمل مع تسلم
ادواتها وبعد دورات مكثفه خضع لها احد
افراد الاسره مشروع كفاله
الاقتصادف
2012 يتيم في كفاله تعليميه معيشيه شهريه
لمده سنه كامله بالاضافه الى ذلك تم تمكين
اسرهم اقتصاديا في عدد 50 اسره واليوم همم
نسلم هذه الاسر حقائب المهنه لكي يستطيعوه
ان يعولوا انفسهم مستقبلنا
الخياطه وصيانه الجوال وصناعه الحلويات
والمعجنات والبخور ضمن 11 مجالا تدربت
عليه ربات الاسري او اكبر ابنائها من 50
اسره من الايتام
وادوات لمشاريع مدره للدخل يمكن ان تحقق
الاكتفاء الذاتي للاسره
يعني كفاله سنه والحمد لله والان دخلت في
مجال الكوافير ولله الحمد وانا متفائله
جدا بهذا المشروع الذي ان شاء الله مع
الزمن والوقت اطوره لكم مشروع اكبر
[موسيقى]
سيره الجوال والان الحمد لله اقدر اسرتي
تتنوع ومشاريع والتمكين الاقتصاديه لاسر
الايتام والاسر النازحه في مارب التي
يملها مركز الملك سلمان
وقد نجحت خلال السنوات الماضيه تحويل
الاسري من محتاجه الى منتجه
[موسيقى]
لمده عامه يوفره مركز الملك سلمان ادوات
المهنه للمستفيدين الاسر الذين تم تدريبهم
على مهن مختلفه ليكونوا قادرين على اعاله
اسرهم مستقبلنا محمود الحميدي لقناه
العربيه
قريب